ốp cô mua Chi đi 3.000.000 trời ơi cái ốp thôi
đây là lần đầu tiên mà mua cái ốp bên Hàn Quốc mà mắc
đến như vậy hồi xưa giờ xài mấy cái ốp gọi là
trăm à 220 không à
đó 200 rồi đã suy nghĩ rồi đó suy nghĩ 200.000 đã suy nghĩ
nhưng mà vì Chi đi
khỏi nghĩ thiệt sự không phải là
nhiều tiền đâu mà do là rất thích chia ly luôn á
rồi bây giờ mình sẽ khui Cho mọi người coi thử nha
của Khánh Vân á là do của Khánh Vân là
nó có thêm mấy cái trang này nha mọi người
và mọi người coi nè
ở trên đây nó sẽ có rất là nhiều mẫu nha
mình chọn là mẫu này nhưng mà cái mà để gắn lên á
là cái này mà
cái này mà mà nó màu vàng á mọi người nhưng mà hết hàng mà
lúc đầu á là tụi mình đứng á
lúc mà đi ngang qua là thấy nó cực kỳ đông luôn
à ốp này là catify nha mọi người ơi nè
của mình gắn lên nó sẽ như thế này nè
tại vì nó nó sẽ Theo cái tỷ giá của bên Hàn nha đó
cái này á là 55
còn cái này là 77 Won nha mọi người
đây nguyên một cái ốp của mình thì mình hông có mua cái dây
cái dây của Khánh Vân là gần à
600.000 á nè
cái mà mình định chọn là cái này nè là nó chỉ có nút vàng
thôi xong nó hổng có
mỗi mẫu đều hết nha mọi người
nó là cái màu mà xanh vàng mix với nhau á rất là nhiều đa
dạng mẫu luôn
cái mẫu nào cũng xinh hết trơn á
nhưng mà cái giá thì nó hơi chua thiệt nha
đúng
cái mẫu xanh vàng này là cái mẫu mà á nó ế hết rồi đó ồ
ế rồi đó nha BA màu còn lại là nó so down hết rồi
tính mẫu ế mà mọi người coi cái VA li trong đây cực kỳ đẹp
cái VA li 20.000.000 cái VA li
cái VA li hồng của ông Khánh Vân đứng á mọi người
thấy hông mình chèn vô á
trời ơi rất xinh mà 20.000.000 nha
mình nghe nói là nếu mà đem về Việt Nam Á mà nhiều
người order là tầm 22
5 á với mình là thí dụ cái này thì nó sẽ hít được vô luôn
nhưng mà do là
mình là hội chứng sợ lỗ hông
biết có AI có
kiểu sợ lỗ hông nhưng mà tại vì quá thích chia đi
kiểu như cơ hội cũng chỉ có một lần đi qua bên đây thôi
nên mình mua đại luôn mọi người đó
cái màu nó vậy nè thí dụ mà gắn vô thì mọi người có thể gắn
nếu mà nó đồng màu vậy thì
nó nó nó bình thường lắm hiểu hông
mặc dù mà cái này á thì có thể bỏ card vô được
nhưng mà thôi
lấy cái này luôn
tại cái này có thể hít vô được cái tường luôn
nha mọi người
trời ơi mà ở trong cái Store này rất là nhiều mẫu mã mà
nghe nói là cái mẫu này đang collab với CD
mà chắc chắn mọi người coi cái clip này không thể nào có QC
trong clip này rồi nha mọi người ơi
Chi đi hông có mắc cần tụi mình
4 Chi đi không cần 2 con này QC
phụ một mình Chi đi chấp hết
chỉ cần dính cái mặt Chi đi là cháy hàng
dính cái mặt Chi đi ta nói là sold out
nên bây giờ hỏi mình là cái ốp này 3.000.000 mấy
thì mình có thấy phí hông
thiệt sự là phí thì cũng quá phí
nhưng mà vì là chia đi nên hổng thấy là nó cũng
cũng dễ thương
hổng được nên là mua kiểu a cũng xứng đáng
lâu lâu lấy Ra xài thôi chứ cũng sợ nó nó nó nó dơ
nếu cái này dơ nó có nó chùi chùi hông
hồi nãy anh kêu chùi được
vậy hả thổi
còn nếu mà sau này mày sợ lỗi mày hổng xài nữa
thì mày Cho Tao còn mày
ê
nhưng mà xinh quá anh đem đây nè thấy hông rất là xinh luôn
à trong đây nha Jam có rất nhiều nhưng mà hỏi tới nha
là chưa hết kiểu như là chỉ còn 2 cái là không bán
thí dụ mà còn tầm BA cái trở lên hay SAO mới bán
á hồi nãy mày mày mấy cái mày hỏi nó hỏi 2
còn 2 cái là hổng bán
mà rất là nhiều cái mà mọi người ờ
thí dụ mà còn mô hình á ta cũng hổng bán luôn
người ta chỉ thí dụ mà còn dư hàng mới bán thôi
tui năn nỉ cái mô hình đó
ảnh kêu là còn một cái duy nhất là cái mô hình đó
tui năn nỉ hông bán
tại vì trang của nó rất là xinh nè
chèn nha mọi người mấy cái trang nè
trang ở đây rất rất là xinh luôn nè
cái trang mà để mình gắn vô
cái kiểu dạng nè
cái kiểu à treo lủng lẳng lủng lẳng á rất là nhiều mẫu
nhưng mà thật sự là
không phải là người ta chảnh đâu mà Tao nghĩ là
còn một trái đúng rồi
Tao muốn bán hay SAO
Tao để làm hàng trưng bày luôn hông bán ừ
để làm hàng trưng bày luôn mà hông biết là
những cái Store khác như thế nào
nhưng mình nghĩ là mỗi trái đều là có duyên hết
mình là bạn Thủy mình hồi xưa
giờ mình thích là màu xanh nước biển
mà cái màu vàng mix vô quá đẹp
trời ơi mua cái ốp 3.000.000 mấy
ê với người có tiền là bình thường nha ừ
với người có tiền bình thường
tại mình đẹp nhớ 2 con này là hơi lố thôi
có thiệt sự bây giờ AI mà coi cái clip đó ủa
có 3.000.000 mấy mà
SAO 2 con này nó làm rần Ben vậy ta
một cái ốp của mày là bằng BA cái mắt kiếng rồi ừ
ê bây giờ chuẩn bị nè chuẩn bị inbox cái tập tiếp Theo nè
mắt kính nha mọi người ơi
BA cái này nè
đó là thì chỉ còn thêm vài à vài 10 con
thôi là bằng BA cái này nè
thêm vài 10 con là bằng BA cái mắt kính này luôn
á tính Ra BA cái mắt kính còn xài được lâu nha
còn xài hoài là xài đa dạng
còn cái ốp thì cũng chỉ gắn được có một một cái a
cái điện thoại vậy thôi
nhưng mà thôi
đó là Chi đi đúng là Chi đi ảnh xứng đáng mà
cái hôm mà mình với Khánh Vân mà coi ở ngoài à
sân vận động Mỹ đình
á được gặp Chi đi rồi được gặp Chi đi rồi
Chi đi
ê nổi da gà nha má
thiệt hông phải là cái gì
nhưng mà nổi da gà giống như ọc khi mà
chia đi bước Ra như một ông hoàng vậy
đó có nghĩa là lúc đó mình
công nhận là
mình có hơi over xíu tại vì SAO chỉ gặp một lần thôi đó
Cho tới Tao hét Cho tới thì thôi mày bị thao túng
mày bị thao túng nhưng mà thật sự là
ảnh bước lên sân khấu
mọi người ơi thật sự là bị nổi da gà luôn á
kiểu vô từ cái dạy nó mới nói là ôi mặc dù
ê nhưng mà Tao là fan mà kiểu fan là fan non á
kiểu như là nếu mà hỏi sâu vậy đi thì Tao hổng biết nha
nhưng mà yêu hỏi yêu mến chị đi hông là rất mê
mê lắm là fan ruột nè con ừ đây là fan ruột
tại biết SAO hông cái gì nó cũng có dán hình trong nhà
có lightstick có gì nó cũng có hết trơn còn mình là fan
lề đường thôi
lề đường nhưng mà vẫn mua một cách đường đường chính
chính hổng có mua hàng F
a k e đâu nha
chưa có hàng F
e đâu chưa có hả chưa chưa có hả nè là mới có luôn hả ừm
cám ơn mọi người nha
nhớ Ra cái clip này hông phải là để khoe hay gì hết
chỉ là thật sự rất là thích